There is a Congressman named Greg Meeks who
recently announced that he's supporting Michael
Bloomberg in the democratic primary.
Now, Gregory Meeks is a Democrat and he is
black and Bloomberg has been having some issues
lately with comments about stop and frisk
and black Americans.
And so these endorsements from minority members
of Congress are really important to Michael
Bloomberg being able to continue crafting
a narrative that is something other than the
vile racist, uh, which has been the characterization
of Bloomberg over the last couple of weeks.
Well, Greg Meeks is helping to craft that
narrative.
He showed up on CNN, he pulled the tired old,
but Bernie isn't a Democrat talking point,
which is a lame talking point to start with
because it's not about issues.
It's just a party membership argument.
It's a form of exclusive tribalism, but it's
extra hilarious because Bloomberg just changed
from being a Republican to being a Democrat.
So there's a ton to talk about here.
Let's first watch the clip.
Notice that Greg Meeks doesn't talk about
any policy here.
It doesn't talk about who's better on healthcare,
who's better on economics, nothing.
It's just Bernie isn't really a Democrat.
Take a look.
The difference for me is Bernie Sanders is
not a Democrat.
So I don't understand why Bernie Sanders,
who does not want to become a member of the
democratic party, he would run.
And if he wins rule, you know, why does a
Democrat run as a Democrat?
We've asked him on a continuous basis, if
in fact you want to be the democratic nominee,
you should be a Democrat.
If you're not a Democrat, you should not run.
He should run as an independent.
Uh, he's not a Democrat.
So to me, I wouldn't allow a Republican to
run as a Democrat or for the democratic governor
run in the democratic.
I don't think he should be a Democrat.
I think that he should say if he wants to
be a Democrat, he should register in the democratic
party.
And then you can talk about running and to
be my representative, I want a Democrat to
be my representative, uh, as president of
the United States would be my nominee.
And he raised a whole lot of money.
You'll see what happens.
Thank you very much.
God.
Pleasure.
Okay.
So first of all, debate the issues.
If you support Bloomberg and not Bernie, argue
why Bloomberg is better than Bernie on the
issues, what's their position on healthcare,
on education, on inequality, on for like whatever.
Just pick a topic and argue why the person
you're supporting is better than Bernie, if
that's what you want to argue.
Repeating.
What was it four times there in a minute that
Bernie isn't a Democrat is not an argument.
I don't care about tribalism and party, but
then it's layered too, which is if you want
to play the party game.
Bloomberg was a Democrat until 2001 then became
a Republican to run for mayor, then became
an independent in 2007 to continue this sort
of persona of the independent thinker and
then became a Democrat in 2018 just a year
and a half ago, a presumably as a pretext
for what he is now doing, running for the
democratic presidential nomination.
So it's all BS and the reality is meek says,
well, Bernie should just switch to being a
Democrat.
Uh, now if, if, uh, he was running in the
democratic primary, if Bernie did that, they
would say Bernie's pandering.
If Bernie Sanders took this guy's advice,
said, I am going to become a Democrat.
If he did it, then Greg Meeks would be saying,
this is pandering.
I don't, I want a real Democrat, not a guy
who switches his nomination.
Uh, his party registration just to run for
president, which is exactly what the guy he's
supporting did Michael Bloomberg.
So it's can't win for Bernie on this.
Greg Meeks would be the first to say Bernie
is only switching to pander.
But then because Bernie did not switch party
registration, meek says, well, he's not really
a Democrat.
I want to vote for a Democrat.
But then the most important thing again is
that none of this has to do with who's going
to be better for you on wages.
Who's going to be better for you on healthcare?
If for Republican ran with the right policies
against Trump, I'd support the Republican.
Now, in reality, no one with those socially
democratic policies that I support would be
a Republican in 2020 United States.
But it's besides the point, I don't care about
party registration.
Note also that Bernie is in the democratic
leadership in the Senate.
He's not just some outsider who has no integration
with the democratic party, so it's a circular
firing squad argument.
It will never get anywhere.
Anyone who makes this argument already shows
they don't really care about reason and rationality.
And then the problem is anyone who tries to
argue with somebody like Greg Meeks about
this is also going to fail because it's an
unwinnable argument no matter what.
They will say why Bernie is wrong in this
particular case, and then zoom out as of December,
2019 Gallup says only 28% of Americans are
registered Democrats.
So what exactly are you trying to do by saying
if you aren't part of the club, we don't want
you when 72% of the country isn't part of
that club and is not a demo or aren't registered
democratic voters, it's pointless tribalism
and it doesn't actually deal with the issues,
which is what I care about.
Tell me what you think about this.
Bernie's really a Democrat
meme that is continuing to sort of spread
like a virus in some circles.
Let me know
on Twitter.